hello everyone welcome to simply learn
this is abit i'm your teaching assistant
to your host for today's session
just wanted to confirm am i audible are
you able to hear me you can use the chat
window to confirm
please type your question okay wonderful
great responses great audience
uh
thank you thank you so much for your
responses everyone
first of all uh welcome to today's
session oh i see a lot of intense people
joining in today um
okay let's get started oh we have our
trainer
and it or no the speaker and it was one
of the best in providing certification
training workshop and courses for
like pmp prince2 cbap itil most uh
change management
okay she's one of the best and she she
also does this so mentor all the
students enrolled in master programs in
expert project management or itl expert
man
masters so let me quickly bring annette
who will start the session and uh just
to give you a heads up how exactly we
proceed on today's session of basic
ground rules everyone will be on mute in
order to avoid the background noise you
have any question you can just put it on
the chat window so
do select all audience entire audience
all participant options so that your
question can be seen by everyone myself
and and it so that in case i have the
answer uh i'll reply to it
okay so with that being said um there
will be a survey at the end of the
session do not skip the survey we we
need your inputs we need your available
feedback please provide your feedback
uh on on the session hosting myself
trainer content any any question you
have just put it on um feedback
about your experience okay and uh at the
end of the session there will be a 15
minutes hurdle to answer all your
questions so how how we answer your
question is again you'll put the
question in the chat window our
trainer or myself will read the question
and we will proceed with answering that
so that's about uh the 15 minutes apart
uh at the end of the session so let's
stick to the schedule and understand uh
the importance of the time on everyone's
end so
you have any queries or apart from the
session or after the session you have
any questions do not hesitate to bring
that on our
community forum which is at
www
com
i repeat it's community.simplylearn.com
it's an open forum for each one of you
anybody has any question uh you can
select the course as per your course our
content you can just go ahead and put
the question
myself and it or any of our trainer or
smes will answer the question within 24
hours so with that with that being said
and without any further ado i'll pass
the presidential rights i hope this
session will motivate you all to be a
part of you simply learn
thanks thanks once again
uh and it
yes i alright just
get my screen shared here so everyone
can actually see it definitely oh here
we go
okay you should be able to see the
monitor right now and our course title
is how i failed my pmp can everyone see
that all right if you could just send me
a chat or a question to say yes
that would be fantastic okay great well
i'm not going to slow down i've got a
lot of material i want to share with you
to help get you through your exam
and get you a as a to be a pmp
credentialed project manager
so we don't want you to have to tell
this story here's how i failed my pmp so
we're going to give you some information
and tips that's going to help you crack
the exam on your first attempt and pmp
the exam for the simply learned students
we have a very high success rate in the
98 to 99 percent
percentile of pass on their first
attempt across our various different
exams
i'm not going to spend a lot of time
with myself other than to say i have
several certifications i've written many
exams so i can
certainly share in
me i haven't failed one yet
the time may come but for now i'd have
passed them all so some of it i'll share
some of my personal tips with you as
well as some tips that i've
gleaned from research on how people
learn
so what i'm going to take you through is
just very briefly the value of the pmp
certification the requirements to sit
the exam
the application process
some things you'll need to be aware of
before you actually appear for the exam
because there are
certain things that you need to to know
and bring with you
then we're going to go through some
study tips how to prepare mentally and
things we don't want you to do
things that will be counterproductive to
you passing the exam and then we'll open
up the floor to questions and i will do
my best to provide answers to them if at
any point you do have a question feel
free to either raise your hand in the
attendees uh
box or to chat or send the question
through the question box and i'll do my
best to answer it my job is to manage
the time so if i get too many questions
i may have to leave them till the end
but i will do my best to answer them as
we go along because research shows us
you'll retain the answer and the
information better when we do that
why pmp
first of all the industry is set to grow
by 6.6 trillion by 2020.
there will be
41.5 million jobs in project management
by that time
and if we consider that there are less
than 2 million people in the world that
have a certification in either of the
two major certifications it really is
going to let you demonstrate your skills
get recognized as an expert in that area
and really sets you apart
from your peers
we see that organizations
find value in their staff being
certified because they'll pay up to a 20
percent premium so it's definitely worth
setting the time aside to learn how to
manage projects according to the
international global standards and best
practices
so requirements
first things first
pmp
sorry pmi the project management
institute which is the accreditation
body for the pmp certification
will not let you write the exam
until you meet certain criteria one of
those is you must have 35 contact hours
of project management training so that's
35 pdus and one pdu
for pmi is the equivalent of about
one hour professional development
activity
so if you sign up take a question
that report you can check that off your
list of things you must have
the other thing you need is the project
management experience there are two
different avenues you can take here some
of us
may have fallen into project management
without having a university degree
so as long as we have a secondary school
diploma a high school diploma or
equivalent depending on what your
educational system is in your company or
country sorry
and you have five years of project
management experience or approximately 7
500 hours leading and directing projects
then you would qualify
if you have a university degree or the
global equivalent
then you only need three years of
project management experience or 4 500
hours of
leading and directing projects so this
you're going to fill in an application
forms let's take a look at that the
reason how they're going to assess
whether you meet their criteria
is by you filling out either online or
using a paper-based method whichever is
more convenient for you the application
form where you're going to list your
experience
and list the course in your education
require that you've achieved and things
like that
they will then review that for complete
lists and make sure you meet the
requirements
online they will get back to you they
commit to within five days if it's
paper-based of course it takes a little
longer so that could be 10 to 20 days
before they get back to you
once they've approved you to write the
exam
they will then ask you to make your
payment
and once you make the payment they'll
send you a notification indicating
instructions for writing the exam how to
schedule it
and
at this point they may also select you
for audit
so it's an honor based system for the
most part
so you you tell them what you've done
and you know they'll take a look and go
gee only you graduated two years ago you
can't possibly have done all these
things or yeah you've been at this for
30 years it's reasonable but this is the
type of work you would have done or that
these are the types of things you might
have done on this type of project
all that to say that they do
periodically to keep us honest randomly
audit applications so you might get
audited in which case they may want you
to
provide more information about what you
did or they might want to talk to you on
the phone or contact a reference that
can confirm your experience
once you've gotten your notification
that they've accepted your application
and you're allowed to write the exam you
have up to one year from the date you've
registered with them to write the exam
and that's written at any of the
prometric sites worldwide and for those
of you who may not be familiar with
prometric what they do is they
specialize in administering exams on
behalf of organizations like the project
management institute
so they're in located in almost every
country around the world
we can help you pmi will also help you
to locate the center that's closest to
you
so let's take a look at the exam itself
we're going to pass it let's understand
it
it consists of 200 multiple choice
questions
you will have four hours to write the
exam
keep in mind there is no negative
marking for wrong answers answer all the
questions okay so that will be one of
the tips you're going to see on my one
of my future slides here
the questions are developed and
validated globally
by people who have their certification
in pmp
it's developed in accordance with iso
international standards organization
standards for accreditation and testing
so it it sets a high bar
the reference guide so our course covers
all of the material but
the our course and the exam are all
based on the information in the pmbok
guide and the pmbok stands for project
management body of knowledge and it's
based on years of research of what works
in projects and what doesn't works in
projects so
pmi spends a lot of time and money doing
research and assessing and and
continually reviewing best practices to
update
they monitor the exam's validity through
a psychometric analysis and all that
means is they do a lot of statistical
review of the exam and the questions and
how the questions perform in
differentiating those who understand the
concepts and those that don't so for
example if people who scored 90 on the
exam all got one question wrong that
would indicate to them there's something
wrong with the way the question is
worded so they're constantly reviewing
and and and keeping it up to date and
current
if i'm going too fast let me know
the blueprint for the exam an exam
blueprint is just simply
the guidelines for how they select the
questions to include in the exam
so if you're not already aware
the pmbok guide is devoted to
divides up the material into five
process groups or domains
these are initiating a project
going about planning the project
executing the project monitoring and
controlling and closing
and the questions are distributed in
this manner showing where the main
emphasis is and
appropriately reflecting the amount of
time sometimes that we would spend as
well you'll notice planning
is
almost equally weighted with these other
areas
and
i like to quite i believe it was
aristotle i may have the the person
wrong that quoted that a a job well
planned is a job half done
and i i can firmly
uh
tell you that i've seen that in reality
keep in mind only 175
of the 200 questions are scored and
here's why
25 of the questions are pre-test
questions in other words they're
piloting them to make sure that the
students are going to understand what's
being asked
so they're making sure the wording is
clear and then when people read it they
know what's being asked they're not
intending to trip you up with tricks of
wording for example you shouldn't have
to read between the lines
in terms of that kind of stuff they want
to make sure though that you do fully
understand the content
so another exam tip i will get to
shortly is if you get a question on the
exam and it just doesn't make any sense
to you assume it's a pilot question
don't let it throw your game
okay because it maybe it's a bad
question it may not be
that you don't know what you're talking
about you may perfectly well know what
you're talking about but somehow that
question got through all the quality
edits and it's just a bad question okay
so keep that in mind you will not be
able to tell
which one is a test question and or
sorry a pilot question and which one's
not
all right i'm just reading your chats
here let me answer a couple of those
questions
uh hello bangalore india
manjosh good to have you aboard with us
um the powerpoint you will get a video
you'll get the recording of the session
so you'll get the powerpoint with that
also it is an online exam
it is an online exam you don't see a
chat window okay if you go to the top of
your you can get to me through your
questions that's just fine it doesn't so
either one works i have both windows
open also if you go to view at the top
of your little control panel for the
webinar
then you should be able to see a drop
down there that says chat and if you
just click beside it it will uh it will
show your chat window for you
okay i think that's all the questions i
have at the moment so i'll go back to
the content
okay so that's what to expect on the
exam
so here's an example of an exam question
they are scenario based okay so this
this uh the pnp it's not you will get
questions that are strictly you know
what's the definition of a project but
you're also going to get some that are
more complicated such as in this case
where there are two programs running
program a is being cancelled but there
are two projects in that program
that have links to program b
so what they're going to do in this
scenario
is take those two projects and transfer
them to project program b so that
program b can get the benefits of those
two projects and the projects are 50 and
70 complete
so there's a little scenario not super
complicated
but nonetheless you're going to get a
couple of questions on the exam i'm
going to show you one just to give you
an idea of what they would look like
so here's the question
i'm going to let you read through that
because that will better simulate the
exam we have highlighted or bolded the
correct answer here
note you've got to read the question
carefully
so there's nothing wrong with doing some
of these other things they all look
correct right
however
before you do anything you really need
to assess what are the benefits
of making their different reporting
structures etc consistent with program b
those are the types of questions that
you'll get read the question carefully
sometimes it's what's the best option
sometimes it's going to ask you what's
the first thing you should do
so all the answers may be correct but
they're asking you for the first thing
you should do or the second thing you
should do or what a certain role should
do
on the project and that's how they're
going to read whether you really
understand it doesn't give you every
single detail but that's okay we rarely
get every single detail when we're
managing a project do we
we typically get
bits and pieces of information and we
have to read between the lines
and that's what they're testing our
ability to do on these types of
questions
i'm just i'm just reading your questions
here just a second
the um
we do learn by the knowledge areas
we okay so so the question is is it
better to learn by groups or knowledge
areas it depends on how you think of it
the pmbok is organized by the knowledge
areas and with each knowledge area it it
discusses how
the knowledge area is
applied across the process groups so
it's probably easier to follow the
layout of the pmbok and do the knowledge
areas and walk through the process
groups okay
yes i can all of this information is
also on the pmi website and i'm going to
give you the link to that if you don't
already have it
but it's all on the pmi website so i
just cut and paste this grid from the
pmi website for you because sometimes
it's a little hard to travel down and
find things so i'm just trying to bring
out some of the really highlighted
information that would be of interest to
you
oh yeah uh okay so the question about
you started your application but you
haven't finished it and it's been 10
weeks i don't believe that that's going
to flag it for audit at all
they'll understand you people get busy
you're trying to do projects so that's
not an issue you don't need to restart
it you can just go ahead and complete it
when you when you're ready
so that's not a problem
modest you're asking for a question i'm
assuming you want me to open up the mic
for you
just let me find your name here
okay i've just opened up your mic
okay thank you
hi my question is
okay this i'm so sorry we can't hear you
there's too much background noise and
interference there so if you wouldn't
mind chatting out your question or
entering it into the question box i'll
try one more time to open your mic but
okay i've opened it again let's try
again
okay
yeah it's too loud sorry about that it's
it's just too loud we just can't make it
out
all right so i'm gonna some of these
questions
i'm going to
answer at the end because i think i'm
going to answer some of these
i'm going to answer some of these
questions afterwards
because i believe my presentation will
actually cover them okay so we had an
example question here
so tips for preparing to the for the
exam go to the website for pmi
get the pmp handbook off their website
i'm going to give you the website at the
end of the course but it's pmi.org
pmi.org is the website and i'll show it
to you in a slide at the end
download the handbook everything i'm
telling you is in the well everything
about the technicalities of how you
apply in that are in the pnp handbook so
it'll answer
a lot of your questions they've done a
really good job in the pnp handbook of
putting that together
you can review the current pnp exam
content outline so that document is
where i got that blueprint from and they
have some other information in there
that will be of use to you do go through
that
they've done a great job of pulling
together information that will support
you to get your certification so take
advantage of it
make sure that you complete all of the
practice exams in our course
okay we've put a lot of effort into
making sure that you have more than one
practice exam so that we'll do one
together during the course
so that we can discuss and it helps us
as instructors to know the areas that
that particular class is maybe weakened
and we need to expand on more and then
you have additional exams so if you
don't feel you're ready to write the
exam by the end of the course then you
can
you can do some more studying on your
own do some of the online portions of
the course to reinforce the classroom
learning
and then write another exam
test exam what this does is it lets you
be sure that you've learned the material
rather than just remembering
the answer from the previous the first
time you took the exam so that's why we
have multiple practice exams for you do
do those do them several times if you're
if you're not comfortable
we cover all the material in the pmbok
guide the guide to project management
body of knowledge however
it is good to get that book and read it
front to cover
okay
take the course you don't need to read
it in advance of the session
if you're taking our course our course
is designed to help speed up and
facilitate your understanding of that
information
so you know by all means if you're more
comfortable read it first
but it's not necessary we focus in the
classroom on the more complicated parts
of the course and the concepts so that
when you are reviewing the guide you
pick it up more quickly
and you're reinforcing your recall we'll
get to some tips on on how to to study
in that in the next couple slides that
will help you understand why that's so
important
i'm just reading questions just one
moment
okay
i again i'm going to go through some of
these slides to make sure we cover them
all and
i believe some of your questions will
get answered
and if not we'll leave 10 to 15 minutes
at the end to definitely do that so
here's the real stuff you want
we don't okay so some of this
information is based on i have a number
of books on education and adult learning
and things like that so this particular
some of these points are actually taken
from a book called brain rules by john
medina
and
brain rule number six tells us we don't
pay attention to boring things
reading the babok front to cover is
boring
i have to confess i found it a little
make it interesting for yourself
when you read a section think about how
that applies to your job and visualize
yourself
applying that information in a fun way
so that you are better able
to
uh
to to stay engaged with the information
repeat to remember that's brain rule
number seven these are all based on lots
of research that john medina and others
have done
if you want to make your long-term
memory more not reliable you incorporate
new information gradually and then you
repeat it at timed intervals so for
example
you might study
one knowledge area
or parts of it then review it after a
couple of days
and then review it again after a week
and again after after a month so you're
constantly reinforcing that information
also by introducing the information
gradually
overwhelm your mind with everything at
once so that it can sort of incorporate
it it gives your your subconscious a
chance to
draw connections between it and other
information that you know
so that's one of the reasons that we
they recommend doing it gradually
we are visual learners most of us some
more so than others so reproduce key
information from memory
and draw yourself a conceptual diagram
maybe that's a mind map if you're not
familiar with mind mapping you're taking
the concepts and showing how they relate
to one another
we could give you one but that's not the
point the point isn't to have one the
point is to be able to produce it
so the learning happens as you're
creating it and trying to figure out
what the relationships are to draw that
diagram to make it make sense
when you can produce those types of
things from memory accurately
now you've learned it and if you can
periodically come back and reproduce it
at intervals
you're reinforcing it so it'll speed up
your recall and confidence on the exam
another tip is uh if i don't know when
i'm producing these types of things or
trying to for example there's a grid in
the pmbok that shows the knowledge areas
the process groups
and which processes happen within those
i produced that from memory before i
even started to go to the more advanced
stuff
by doing that and if i don't know i look
it up i don't cause myself to wonder
whether i'm remembering when i'm in the
exam right or the wrong answer because
i'm not reinforcing the wrong answer i'm
only looking at the right answer so
always try and do it um
uh accurately if you don't know look it
up that way you'll only remember the
right answer because it's the only
answer you let into your head
set aside a regular time to study and be
disciplined about it
that's the hardest one for most of us to
do because it's so hard when everything
creeps into our life both from work and
we have family obligations and it's nice
to have a few minutes to relax at the
end of the day and we have to set this
time aside
find out what your most productive time
of the day is and try and set that aside
to do some studying
at a regular interval so you get used to
it simulate the exam environment to the
best of your ability okay so remember
the exam environment is going to be a
quiet room
so to some extent you want to spend some
of your study time in a quiet room or at
least do the practice exams in the quiet
room so it simulates that environment
better
or relax and by this i don't mean put
your feet up and fall asleep but don't
be stressed
if you can study when you're stressed
the research also shows us and this is
from the accelerated learning handbook
by dave mayer
page 37 if any of you are interested in
getting that book
tells us that if we are feeling stressed
and overwhelmed our brain shuts down and
goes into its more reptilian state where
it's focused on survival when that
happens we don't learn as well because
we're in more of a reactive than a
a higher functioning mode so try to be
as less as as little stress as possible
while you're while you're studying
and i do realize that that is much
easier said than done
okay the other one is
try to
use your voice
and by this we're talking about uh that
as well as movement but we want to
integrate all of our senses in in our
western culture here and i know you have
people here from all over the world but
western culture we sort of have this
concept that learning is all in our head
but studies have shown that it's not we
actually learn by physically moving and
participate so when you're drawing your
conceptual diagram it's not a lot of
movement but you are moving your arms
and your hands and you're seeing
visually as well if you talk to yourself
or talk out loud about how you're doing
you're also picking up the audit
auditory senses for remembering and
learning and it's been proven that all
of those combined will help us learn and
retain the information better
so if you live with someone else and
they hear you talking to yourself while
you're studying tell them there's
scientific evidence to prove that that
actually does help because you your your
involving as many senses as possible in
in absorbing that information
okay so
those are some were some tips on
studying
so when you write the exam here are some
tips for writing the exam
answer all the questions
i always go through
and this is usually recommended by
others as well do a first pass to the
exam quickly answering all the questions
there is a facility to let you flag
questions you're not sure about or
you're not confident about so you can
come back and review them later
the objective here is to get through the
entire exam without having to to rush
too much what you don't want to have
happen is you get halfway through the
exam a four-hour exam
and look up to realize you only have one
hour left
and then you have to go to too fast so
set yourself a steady pace practice this
with your practice exams
get through the entire exam
flag the questions you're not sure about
then come back
so set a pace that leaves you time to
review and come back to questions you're
not sure about
this way you won't have to worry about
running at a time and then not getting
marks for you know a certain percentage
of them
remember there are pilot questions
okay this is a really important one uh
lots of people i hear about hear from uh
will tell me that they panicked when
they got one of the got to one of the
questions and and it didn't make any
sense to them and they thought they
hadn't studied enough
okay it could just be a wrong pilot
question remember when we went back we
had all of our our study tips here
whoops too far
relax don't be stressed all those kinds
of things looking at concepts repeating
to remember if i say relax and try not
to be stressed what happens if we hit a
pilot question and we're not aware it's
a pilot we automatically tend to assume
we're wrong and we panic
okay so remember this pilot questions if
it doesn't make any sense to you
give yourself a break assume it's the
question that's the problem and move on
answer it to the best of your ability
and move on because there are 25 of
those questions that aren't even scored
and it's most likely that that's one of
them
okay i'm trying to get through the exam
i want to open it up because there's a
lot of questions here i want to open up
for questions i also want you to share
tips you have at the end of the session
about what works for you because we all
learn differently
so mental preparation
so before you you may have studied you
know the information visualize yourself
passing the exam
visualize yourself
doing well on it there are studies
showing that when we visualize ourselves
in a certain sense it's more likely to
happen
okay
exercise
i know everybody says this and we all
groan and go yeah yeah whatever and we
ignore it but again the studies show us
that when we exercise it boosts our
brain power this is brain rule number
two from john medina's book
and it improves our thinking skills
so any kind of movement and it doesn't
mean you have to go out and run a
marathon but try and get some exercise
maybe before you go for the exam on and
during the time that you're preparing
for the exam
make sure you're well rested
our attention executive functions
working memory our cognitive skills our
logical reason reasoning etc all of
those are required to pass the exam
right
so make sure you're well rested this
also applies to when you're studying if
you're studying tired
then all those things i mentioned like
attention executive function working
memory
logical reasoning are going to be
impaired and it's going to mean it's
going to take you longer to study and
absorb the information
minimize stressors this goes back to
what i was saying earlier about
being
relaxed
so
brain rule number four tells us that
stressed brains don't learn in the same
way
and the worst type of stress is feeling
helpless
so visualize yourself doing well you are
not helpless in this exam you study you
work you talk to other people about it
some other techniques are to uh when
you're using your voice you know tell a
friend or partner what you've learned
and let them know that you don't expect
them to maybe understand but just
telling and explaining it to someone
else and you hearing yourself talk will
help you retain the information better
okay so what you don't want to do
do not cram the night before you're not
going to retain the information and
you're going to be tired the next day
don't think negatively think positively
think about how well you're going to do
and just accept that yeah there's going
to be a few questions that are going to
stop you but that's normal it's not
cause to think you're going to fail
so and don't envision yourself failing
because that's the best way to make sure
that it happens
do not skip reviewing the pmbok you need
to go through that manual to reinforce
what you're thinking and to reinforce
your recall of that information
you can review it and be building the
conceptual diagrams etcetera that i was
talking about earlier when you pull them
together so that's an another way to
help reinforce the information
you can review it along with the slides
from the course when you take the course
to also help reinforce that learning
don't arrive at the exam center late
because what happens when we're running
late we're running late we get stressed
right
because we're worried are we going to
get there in time and that creates all
those negative things that we talked
about in terms of impairing our mental
capabilities
just before we get to the exam and when
you're there late you don't even have
any time to relax and sort of calm
yourself and get your
mentally self mentally prepared for the
exam so you don't want to arrive late
get there early
so you've got time to submit familiarize
yourself with the area
just in case there's a few other people
ahead of you it might take a little
longer for the person to get you you're
registered you want to leave time for
that
so
what do you do after you've passed the
actually i've got these slides out of
sequence let me do this so when you
appear for the exam you want to go early
to the prometric center
you will need to take appropriate
picture identification
what they're doing here is they're
making sure that you don't send somebody
else to write the exam in your place so
you're going to need valid
identification you will get information
and guidance from either pmi or
prometric about what identification is
acceptable in your country okay dress
comfortably
you last thing you want to be is cold
and focusing on being cold instead of
the exam or hot so you're going to want
to
make sure that you you dress in layers
you can take things on and off all
common sense things here
keep in mind you can't take anything
into the exam room
so
don't
bring a bunch of stuff with you if you
have any
special needs
contact the exam center in advance so if
you need wheelchair access for example
if you're diabetic and need to have food
with you those things can all be
accommodated but contact them in advance
find out what the rules are around it
and most places and parametric
definitely does
accommodate those types of things okay
so just let them know well in advance if
you have any special needs and they can
assist you
so
you've appeared for the exam all excited
ready to go you've followed all the exam
tips for studying and you're prepared
and you pass that exam so what's next
next you're going to need to maintain
your certification so it's valid for
three years
it's uh
over a three-year period you need to get
60 professional development units okay
you need to report those
in the continuing certification
program into their system so the
continuing certification reporting
uh program
if you don't report
and they don't accept
your your valid
professional development units they will
suspend your certification
they will suspend it for one year so you
will have a grace period so to speak to
get the pdus and report them
if however after the one-year suspension
you still have not completed the pdus
and reported them and had them accepted
they'll cancel your certification and
you will have to start the certification
process over again which means you'll
have to do the application and
the exam you do not want to have to do
that
okay
there's good guidelines in the handbook
and they have a handbook on their site
about what the different valid
credentialing requirements are
i'll get to this at the end of our
presentation but we also do offer a you
know post certification webinar that
i'll be running on the 29th that talks
about how you can go about maintaining
and other things beyond just the
credentialing
portions of getting your pmp
to help advance your career so you can
tune in with us on on that session as
well
so i'm going to go through questions now
and answers i'm going to go back and
read your chats i'm going to do it in
reverse order
oh yeah if you're the project
coordinator if they've delegated some of
the project management responsibilities
so the question was you know you've got
the bachelor degree you've worked for
three years as a project coordinator but
not actually managed and directed the
project team they do need you to manage
and direct the program however
it may be
coordinated
[Music]
views you'd really need to go through
carefully and and after you've taken the
course or if you read through the pmbok
you'll see the types of things it would
need to qualify if you did those as a
project coordinator then you may be able
to
get some of the experience however
it's highly unlikely
that you will have in the three years
all of your project coordination
experience will be in that line so you
may need a bit more experience before
you can do that
um
i don't
think the pd that's a good question how
long are the pdus valid i'm going to
have to look that up because i'm not
positive but i do know it certainly
lasts longer than a year you've got at
least one year after you've taken the
course i don't believe they expire but
it might be that you need to have it in
the last three or four years because
there have been upgrades to
the project management best practices
over that time so it's not going to i
don't think it's going to be
indefinite but i will have to get back
to you i will post something on our
community forum to that effect
excellent question
most people take the course and then
write the exam fairly quickly so i don't
get i haven't had that question much
all right i'm going to back up and go
from the beginning here a bit
the the exam is based on the pmbok
version 5. so it's the fifth edition
for those of you that were asking that
question
uh the pass mark for the exam is seventy
percent i'm sorry i should have that
this is the first time we've actually
run this seminar i will add that to
the the slides i should have had that in
there
pass mark
okay
all right next question
okay we've got a question here
it is necessary okay so the question is
once and for all do you need to read the
babok twice or at least once you need to
read it at least once
i would not expect to pass the exam
without reading it once
you may supplement with rita or crows or
other similar books i did not when i
wrote the exam the questions are based
on the pmbok
everything else is someone's
interpretation of the pmbok and they can
be excellent
i have not used them so i can't comment
on individual ones but i have heard from
other students who have used them that
they found rita's and crows very useful
so it depends on your learning style if
you find the pmbok absolutely impossible
to understand then by all means get some
you know take our course materials in
addition to some of these other books
and supplemental books and review them
in parallel with
what you're reading in the box or sorry
the pmbok but make sure you read through
that pmbok at least once because it's
going to use the exact terminology
and present the exact
information that the exam is based on
so you do need to read it once
if you
join as a member of pmi
you will get a reduction on your exam
fee equivalent to your membership
and you can download the pmbok for free
it's also a very useful reference when
you're working on projects i use it all
the time
i frequently go back and look up to make
sure that i haven't forgotten anything
and use it as a checklist it's a best
practice it's best practice because it
illustrates ways you do things that will
make the project
the most
chance of having it being completed
successfully
so when we get in a rush we ten times
get get uh pressured by people to cut
corners when you're in a rush is not the
time to cut the corners these are best
practices because they're shown to make
the projects run
most efficiently and effectively so when
you're in a rush why would you want to
cut corners that are proven to give you
the best advantage
then you've asked to have your mic open
i will go and do that right now
okay
i've opened your mic up you're done
erin dunn are you there
you may have wandered off i'm going to
close the mic back up again
just either raise your hand or send me a
chat if you uh
and nerd i noticed you have your hand up
okay go ahead
hey so actually i had a small query
regarding what are the benefits that
one get by getting the pmi membership
i just
heard that you mentioned that one gets
a free pmbok guide additionally
yeah you'll get a few things um if you
go on to their website they'll give you
a full list but basically i mean it's
one of the memberships i do maintain of
the certifications because you get
access to their resource library as well
so you get you know current information
and studies on project management best
practices which can be helpful when
you're trying to pitch the approach you
want to use in a project you'll get the
free pmbok you can download it which is
handy because then you have a pdf
version of it that's searchable
so that's one thing you also get a
discount on your exam fee
so certainly if you're if you don't have
your credential yet and you're planning
to write the exam you get your money
back and then some you save money by
signing up so if for no other reason
it's beneficial from that perspective
but then you do get access to other
information
you can also um get access to the
different forums and discussion groups
that they have when you're a member as
well
does that fully answer your question
i think you've got good so
go ahead yeah so yeah that's good and uh
do we have some say
membership groups and all that are going
around
maybe we could have some discussions and
hear them people speaking something
absolutely pmi has chapters all over the
world uh so they aren't in every single
city but certainly major centers usually
have a pmi uh
group or chapter as they call it and
they'll usually have a monthly meeting
and they'll have different speakers and
they'll have different events that
they'll hold so that people can network
and share stories and share best
practices and what's worked and what
hasn't worked so they definitely have
that they also have special interest
forums on the pmi
site as well so that you can
electronically network and share
information with people and network that
way
anything else
and you can find your local chapter
for for pmi
on their website so when you when you
sign into their website that there's if
you search you'll find local chapter
then it'll help you figure out where
your closest one is
and i'm going to try your mic again
yeah hello hello hi
i can hear you go ahead yeah so i have
uh two questions one question uh is that
the past mark is based on
175 questions excluding pilot already
excluding pilot
excluding the pilot questions
okay
number one number two is that uh
for simply learn if i go for the
self-paced online uh
learning
does it
confirm
yes that'll meet your
yes it meets your pd your 35 pdu hours
okay thanks thank you so you you can do
it either in the live classroom which is
similar to what we've just been doing or
you can do the self-study portion
whichever is you know best for your
learning method
just to ask you on your experience what
do you suggest
to go for the classroom or listen
it depends if if you if you find that
it's helpful to be able to ask questions
real time and clarify your concerns it's
usually you usually get through the
material faster in understanding it
better with the live class however
that's not for everyone
lots of there are people who prefer to
just read it and absorb it on their own
so it really depends on you i like
taking the live class
yeah if i answer the questions and get
through it more quickly but yeah yeah if
i take the life class will i have access
to the materials and those things from
people simply learn absolutely you'll
get access to the same materials that
you will if you do the online or you do
the just the online portion the
difference is you have someone to walk
you through it
and that you can ask questions to real
time
if you have to miss one of our classes
not a problem we record them and we
you'll have access to the links in your
learning management system so if you go
to your pmp course in the learning
management system you'll be able to
download the recorded session so at
least you can hear what the conversation
was from the group as well
correct correct my last question
for downloading the pm uh pmbok
i have to do the registration first with
the pmi right you have to sign up as a
member you don't have to register for
the exam they're two completely separate
things so you can join as a member
even if you're not going to write the
exam and still download the pin bot for
free
yeah okay so for
getting the registration is there any
fees or i can just uh registration
to become a member um you do have to pay
a fee i believe it's 125 dollars
but if you're going to write the exam
they discount your your exam fee by 125
dollars
plus you get the book for free which is
around i think it's around 70 for the
book
so it's better that i get the
registration first
absolutely
yeah thanks thanks the other thing to
keep in mind we do have a master's
program for project management and
that's not the topic for this session so
but i do run a session on that if you're
interested you can you can sign up for
it
if you're taking the pm if you're
planning to take additional courses
after you get your pmp
you will want to do the pnp first
because then the additional courses so
for example if you're taking itil
as well as the pmp courses
do the pmp first
because
the professional development units have
to be taken after you were certified so
if you do your itil certification first
and then take your pmp your itil
certification won't count you won't be
able to claim those as professional
development units if you do the pro the
pmp first
and then take the itil course
then those pdus count towards your
recertification cycle
so just something to keep in mind if
you're planning to take more than just
the pmp course through any provider
is to make sure you understand the
sequencing of them in terms of how to
get the most value for your your
training dollar there
okay assume i'm going to open the mic up
for you go ahead
hey i'm actually uh i am not in i.t
services and it is usually a perception
that uh bmp courses for id people i am
in oil and gas industry for last 10
years and i am managing projection
instrumentation field so how it is going
to be beneficial for me
it is going to be just as beneficial for
you as it is in the in the it industry
it is
the pmp they actually have a
construction special interest group
for pmp managing a project and the
approach described in the pmbok is
independent of industry or market
segment or any of those it's described
at the level that it applies universally
so you're still going to get
the benefits of
fewer cost overruns
fewer better management of your risks
better management of resources so you're
going to improve the chances of success
for your project regardless of your
industry
i had on one of the courses i was
teaching i actually had a lady in
education she was a principal at a
school and i was just thrilled because
the principles are just as applicable
regardless of the industry
and they do have for example they do
have uh they call them extensions i
believe uh for you know government uh
type of projects and and the
construction and a few other ones like
that so it's equally beneficial
excellent question
thank you thank you
you're quite welcome let's go down i'm
sort of sticking in the a's i want to
jump down farther in my list i can't see
everyone uh
jen
i'm going to open your mic up for you go
ahead
hello
hi i can hear you go ahead
okay so my question is uh simple
uh recently in one of the forums for
project managers i've heard that there
is a sixth edition which is getting uh
introduced down the line so i just want
to know when it is applicable because uh
if we're gonna try and learn on the
fifth edition and
you know the sixth edition comes in
place so we should not be evaluated or
i'm just really worried or confused that
which one should we follow
that's question number one and i would
like to have more understanding on what
is pilot questions
okay no problem the sixth edition will
not be applicable till at least 2017.
so the exam will continue to be based on
the fifth edition until at least 2017.
uh we are in regular contact with all of
the certification bodies that we teach
courses for and they give us advanced
warning when they're changing so we
realign our material and make sure that
that's available to people as they go
along so for example the certified
business analysis professional course is
going to switch over to the new exam in
the fall so i'm helping
and we're currently rewriting that
course the same will happen for this
a tip for you i'm just going to turn
your mic because i've got a bit of
background right and then i'll uh i'll
open it back up voices
cutting out
yeah
okay i was just uh
i'm just closing your mic to get rid of
some of the background noise and i'll
open it back up when i'm done to see if
i've answered your question fully
so
here's there are advantages to passing
the exam on the fifth edition number one
they grandfather you in to the future
versions 99 of the time so rarely other
than itil where they have a bridging
thing you typically don't need to
rewrite the exam
i don't know the full content
yet
i have started to review their draft
version but i haven't gotten through all
of it yet but typically the events for
the newer versions are much longer so
the c-vap for example went from 250 to
500 pages so there could be that much
more you have to remember you're still
going to want to know it okay so don't
get me wrong those enhancements are
going to be important and as a
professional you're going to want to
understand them and apply those new
practices that they're talking about but
there's a difference between having to
memorize them to reproduce regurgitate
that information on an exam and being
able to reference the sixth edition
while you're working
to use and apply it
so i would suggest there are benefits to
going ahead and getting your certificate
your certification sooner rather than
later
and don't worry about which exam if it
gets close to the deadline you might
want to worry but otherwise no all right
your second part of your question was
about the pilot questions
so the pilot questions are just there's
25 of them on the exam
the pilot questions are questions they
intend to use on future exams
as part of their quality control they
include them on the live exam
to make sure that the students
understand them correctly
so as i was uh
may not have clarified i can't clarify
this earlier or not so for example if
all of the people who scored really well
on the exam for example you know all the
people who got 90 or above if every one
of them got a pilot question wrong that
would indicate to them that there's
something wrong with the pilot question
and it was misunderstood
so then they would go back and look at
it and maybe change it before they made
it a counting question so one that
counted towards your score so they're
protecting you from their mistakes
basically by including those
and just making sure that they actually
are testing what they expect and that
they're understood by the by the
students
i'm just going to open your mic back up
does that fully answer your question
um still we have some doubts on the
final questions so are we uh we will be
aware of you know that this set of
questions our pilot question no they're
not going to be
okay no you you aren't and they can't
tell you because if they do then people
just wouldn't answer them they wouldn't
be able to test their validity
so it is like a randomly they pick it up
and they uh
account it for us yeah that's right yeah
they'll mix them in throughout the exam
and you won't be able to tell which
one's a pilot versus which one's a real
question
and that gives them a true test of
whether the question is a good question
or not
okay
and
if
you know if if they account those
questions
and so out of uh 200 questions so
correct me if i'm wrong there will be
uh will be
measured
on 175 and correct those 25 questions if
we
answer it correct and
let's say 20 questions we answered it
correct and uh you know those 20 come
out to be as pilot questions
so that will be pulled out completely
right that's how correct that's correct
also though if you get 20 of them wrong
they're pulled out
it can work both ways
okay
thank you all right you're quite welcome
just let me see who else has their their
hand up here
and deya
i just opened your mic up for you
yeah hi so i have a question on the past
percentage uh you mentioned 70 as a
cut-off rate so do we need to have that
in each knowledge area or is it the
whole
it's on the whole
so as an actor
if you get like uh
correct on the initiating and
remaining on the other knowledge areas
overall the total will be like greater
than 70
is that fine or
yes that's fine
they also when you fill in the
application they'll ask what areas
that you have experience in and they
understand that not everyone gets
involved in every project so for example
i'm a consultant so
sometimes i'm involved in the initiation
but other times they bring me in after
they've initiated the project so they do
appreciate that you know not everyone
will have the experience equally divided
across the different knowledge areas so
it's the percentage pass rate is based
on overall on the exam
you don't need to get 70 of the
questions in each of the different uh
process groups correct
okay
okay thanks good great question
swervarden i do apologize if i'm not
pronouncing your names properly
let me get your michael okay go ahead
yeah you pronounce my name correctly
you can call me sri anyway i mean a
couple of things which i
mean which i was noticing is
the one which you mentioned about the 70
is because i already took the exam in
february
this year
unfortunately i lost it and uh
but in
pmbok and in the pmi site i'm a member
of pmi
it says that i mean you need not get any
any they don't talk anything on
the 70 percentage and 80 percentage
something like that
so
i would just like to
reconfirm that i mean
it is uh stated that
i'm going to go back and check that and
get back it used to be 70 they have
recently updated their site so they may
have changed that so let me go back and
check it and i'll post it to the forum
when we're done
if you've looked and haven't yeah
so
yeah because as per my understanding it
should be i mean it is given even in the
prometric center after finishing the
exam
that
it is
proficient moderately proficient below
proficient and
that's all in the three categories it
has been
segregated basically that's what i have
written in the
uh
chat window earlier okay i was wondering
i mean even with some simply learn i'm
almost i'm there from past six years and
i'm going through the
course material
from pm back 4 to pmbok phi and i also
read the read the book a couple of times
completely
and took the simulation test but
unfortunately i was wondering what went
wrong i mean i was
doing
uh the questions in a reverse
engineering manner which i mentioned in
the chat window but
to to be i mean to to my knowledge i
mean i'm totally surprised with the
result like uh initiation i got below
proficient uh planning i got below
proficient execution also below
proficient everything is below
proficiency except closing is moderately
proficient
so
the criteria
misfired my analysis are i was totally
shocked with the result and i completely
postponed it now
from february to i don't know my
membership will expire in january so i
have to finish by that time so
i wanted to go with the best best uh
approach uh in clearing the exam in the
second attempt now again i'm doing the
simulation tests in the simply learn
how
the simulation tests
yes
how how are you doing on them are you
passing the simulation test
yes i'm doing good in the simulation
test and also i have downloaded some of
the apps over uh
my phone
uh wherein wherever i get time generally
i mean maybe if it is a 15 question
uh test 20 20 question test wherever i
go i just sit and read and
take the test if i am getting about 18
then then only i am i
that is the way actually i attempted the
test first time if it is more than 17 or
18 then
i felt comfortable and even in the
simple
simply learned tests when i got above 80
percent then i attempted the test
but
my test was complete
yeah if you want you can chat to me and
we can take this offline and try and
figure out what's what's going on some
people just freeze on exams too they get
a little bit stressed and that can
really as i was mentioning earlier that
can really affect your performance so it
sounds like you know the material
but for some reason you know it was just
a bad day or you're you're getting
stressed on the exam and that's causing
you to lose focus that's what it sounds
like to me but if you send us a chat we
can try and uh deal with it offline uh
in a little bit more detail because it
sounds like you're doing everything
right
so you want me to write it to you on
your email id or whatever if i haven't
fully answered your question and you
still have questions yes
yeah okay the discussion i've given you
has has has answered your question uh
but i suspect you're just getting
nervous on the exam and that's affecting
your performance by the sounds because
you're doing all the right things
might be because it's been almost like
20 years writing the exams and
but can you can you also uh re-check on
the
percentage of past i am i'm definitely
going to do that and and see i know the
cbap for example they don't publish a
pass mark they don't tell you and it may
be that pmi have switched over to not
publishing the pass mark that's a
possibility i will find that out and i
will post that to the forum uh later
today so that you so that everyone can
get the correct answer for that
thank you okay you're quite welcome i'm
going to take one more maybe two more
quick questions here we're just we're
really running out of time here i'm so
happy everybody's so
active because sometimes we don't get
any questions which
isn't uh
isn't nearly as much fun nadine i'm
going to open yours up i will also
review the chat log after we're done
and post answers to the forum as well
for those of you that we didn't get to
your questions
okay go ahead nadine
thank you miss golding uh could you hear
me properly yes i can i can hear you
loud and clear
all right so uh first of all thank you
for taking out the time and taking us
through the webinar i have two questions
predominantly
one is that once i take the membership
which is
as you said it's 125
i want to take the risk management
professional uh course as well or
certification as well does that mean
that there would be a discount for that
as well
i believe there is
i believe all of you are
that um
the exam so it wouldn't matter which
certification you were logging in with
them for if you're a member you're going
to get the reduction on the exam
right thank you so much the other
question is that uh why do people take
uh a prince2 and a pmp boat
excellent question
excellent question i can answer that
since i have both and i teach both
prince2 is the european standard and
there are other parts of the world as
well whereas pmi is more used in the us
and canada and in north america
i believe
somebody told me it's more predominant
in india i don't know if that's true or
not but i was told that as well so it
depends on your geographic region
prince2 is more prescriptive
there are some you must do things in
prince2 whereas pmp or the pmi approach
is is they're equally valid there's
nothing and nothing they don't
contradict each other they have
different focuses
so
the pmp approach is less prescriptive
and that it doesn't say you know thou
shalt do this
but it focuses more on the techniques
and we'll go into more detail on those
techniques and how the techniques work
prince2 does not focus on the techniques
it figures you can go and find those out
there's lots of websites you can figure
out how to do earned value management
and how to you know rate risks and
things like that but it will tell you
things like you must break a project
into stages you must have a product
description signed off before you start
developing it whereas pmp doesn't tell
you to do that now a good project
manager
and depending on the organizational
culture that will let you be a good
project manager will still want to do
that so this is where the two coexist
quite nicely but if you want to claim
that you're managing a project according
to the prince2 best practices you must
have that signed off first
you can be adhering to pmp
and bend that rule and not do it even
though we all know it's the right thing
to do you can still say you're compliant
with pmi
and not have the product description
signed off before you start developing
it
right so so does that
sorry so does that mean that it's it's
beneficial to take both the
certifications
uh i have been converted and would say
yes
uh the first time i saw a requirement
for both on a con
a request for proposal i thought that
was overkill and that they must have a
specific candidate that they want in
mind because i didn't understand why you
would need both having taken both i do
understand the focuses are different
so there is benefit but my advice would
be
to take the one that is most used in the
market you work in because that's going
to be the most advantageous to you if
you can only do one do that one
learn about the other one as well though
because they're both beneficial so
earned value management is excellent
but it's not addressed in prince2
managing by stages and product
descriptions and how you go about
developing
managing your project by products that
you're producing is highly beneficial
but it's not something that's required
under pmp
in the pmi approach
so they are
and what i'm also starting to see here
in north america is that i'm often now
seeing that they'll ask for either a pmp
or prince2 certification and
occasionally both
in recognition that excellent question
if you take our master's program if
you're interested in taking both you'll
get uh you'll save some money it's a
it's a career path that's been we've
done some research with industry to see
what would be the best thing to be doing
and it goes through it we'll take some
basics in itil you can do prince2 or pmp
or both
and six sigma agile and a few others so
if you're thinking of taking multiple
courses that's a a good way to keep the
cost down and i mentor the pmp or the
project management master program as
well as the itil master program if
you're interested in taking those
i am thank you so much ms golding
welcome
i'm going to have to i'm afraid i'm
going to have to cut a short because i'm
surprised they haven't come on and
kicked me off yet because usually they
need the
the session for another uh another
program i always get in trouble for
running over
answering questions but just let me just
pop through here
okay so we are the world's largest
training destination in the world we
offer various different certificates
programs if you're looking for training
check us out
and then you know as well as others and
compare us and see how we do we do offer
demo courses so for example you can take
a demo course on pmp where i'll walk you
through the cost management modules you
get a feel for the type of training
before you actually have to sign up we
have a money back guarantee if you're
not satisfied with the course we will
refund you so just some of the areas
that we have certifications in this is
not all of them by any stretch
and as i mentioned we offer several
master program courses which lets you
get um additional
uh
industry specific or profession specific
skills that aren't in the primary so for
example in the project management expert
course
yes you're going to get the pmp and you
can do the prints too but you'll also
get the agile and you're also going to
get six sigma and and the lean uh stuff
as well so it's really things that will
enhance your ability to progress in your
career after you get the
certification
i am so sorry we've run out of time
folks do join me again though i am going
to go through the chat window and try my
best to get to all of the questions
and i'll try and post the answer on the
the the forum uh to the best of my
ability
and thank you so much i know how hard it
is to find an hour in your day so i i
really do appreciate that you've been
able to take that hour to spend with us
and i apologize for not getting to all
all the questions
uh you're an amazing group to uh to be
so involved so i would like to see some
of you in my courses because this is the
kind of involvement and question asking
that really makes the learning
experience much richer and helps you
retain the information better
if you don't mind if you could just chat
out to me whether you think you'll be
taking a course with us some of you may
already be enrolled if you're looking
for tips on passing the exam some of you
may already be enrolled in courses so
that would be curious to hear
and i'm going to start the process of
shutting down but i will leave my audio
on for just a little bit longer
if you have a really burning question
chat it out to me and if i can answer it
quickly i will do that
it will take me too long to go back and
read the long list of questions
um
that's interesting uh
and um i didn't i have not experienced
the middle level pm not being required
that is news to me
um
that's interesting
i would be curious as to what market
segments you're working in that that
that's happening in which area of the
world you're in
i frequently see projects where there
are multiple pms where you've got sort
of the main project manager and they
might have a manager looking after you
know vendor management or some of those
things to help support
the project
i would attempt the main exam when
you're doing well on the practice exams
so if you're getting you know 80 my rule
of thumb is if i'm getting 80
on the practice exams then
i i feel i'm ready to write the the real
exam
you're working on projects globally see
it top heavy okay
that's interesting
um
what i'm hearing you say if i'm reading
between the lines correctly is that it's
difficult to get from junior pm to the
senior pm when there's no middle ground
to pass through
i suspect uh
and and do you know any reasons why
they're they're eliminating that middle
level project management
yeah i thought i was gonna say i suspect
it's due to cost they think they can cut
corners
i suspect that that will revert have you
how long have you seen this trend
happening
because
if they don't have the right management
at the right level
projects are going to start to go astray
and they might find that they're not
really saving any money
yeah eight nine months so it hasn't come
full circle yet where they've realized
it's not going to work they may also be
doing the project manager but not
calling them project managers to try and
save cost as well
so if you're one of the people doing
those jobs
you don't have to have the title project
manager necessarily you have to
demonstrate you've done the work
so
if they're not calling you a project
manager but you're still doing the work
then i would i would argue for
uh claiming that on your application and
and see how pmpi rules it
melissa great to see you on the project
management master course
we're going to be having a couple of
mentoring sessions coming up soon so
hopefully you'll log in for those as
well
okay i'm going to have to sign out now
they're they're gonna be
i'm gonna get in trouble for keeping us
this long
thank you so much for your participation
everyone
okay
thank you very much everyone and i am
logging out now
hopefully we'll see you in one of my
courses in the master's program i mentor
or on a future webinar i'll be doing
several of these on different topics
over the coming months
you